some actresses take us by storm  some like the lady we paid tribute to  with an honorary Oscar Steele quietly  into our hearts Myrna Loy had a sweet  way with a sharp line and she could  communicate more with the delicately  raised eyebrow than most performers can  with a raised voice her active career  spanned well over half the history of  movies she was in the first films with  synchronized sound Don Juan and the jazz  singer for a while Hollywood cast her as  an exotic but in the romantic comedies  of the 1930s the true moon have finally  emerged and some of them she and her  great partner William Powell brought  something new to movies the idea that  there could be life after marriage  romantic life that is but in all her  roles she personified Grace and gaiety  warmth and wit and above all  independence of spirit  here from her apartment in New York is  miss Laura congratulations Myrna  you've made me very happy thank you very  much